Позиційна війна в Україні.
Це кадри українських військових з телеграм-каналу 3-ї десантно-штурмової бригади.
Ясно одне: кількість загиблих величезна.
З обох сторін.
А ще - лінія фронту майже не зміщується.
Ми наближаємося до кульмінаційної точки,
яка з військового погляду є точкою, коли ситуація в принципі
знаходиться на межі зрушення в той чи інший бік.
Так вважає військовий експерт Маркус Райснер.
Австрійський офіцер є одним із найвідоміших аналітиків
російської загарбницької війни в Україні.
Він застерігає, що патова ситуація дасть Росії перевагу
в довгостроковій перспективі.
Як до цього дійшло?
Контрнаступ України у 2023 році не приніс бажаних результатів.
Російські танкові пастки, окопи та мінні поля.
Кожна червона точка позначає російську позицію на фронті.
Аналіз супутникових знімків засвідчує,
що російські війська зміцнювали позиції,
поки Україна чекала на зброю від Заходу.
Тут закопано понад вісім мільйонів мін.
Українській армії не вдається пробити лінію фронту.
Українським військовим доводиться економити 155-міліметрові снаряди.
Боєприпасів і зброї не вистачає.
Дилема полягає в тому, що Україна отримує лише те,
що їй потрібно, щоб перетворити асиметричну ситуацію
назад у симетричну, тобто компенсувати перевагу Росії.
Але цього надто мало, щоб фактично загнати росіян у такий кут,
де вони були б змушені йти на переговори.
Захід постачає лише стільки зброї, щоб українці могли утримувати
статус-кво на фронті. Або лише щоб вирівняти асиметрію
на окремих ділянках.
Приміром, зерновий коридор з українського морського порту Одеса.
Росія погрожує топити міжнародні торгові судна,
які вивозять життєво важливе зерно з української житниці для країн Африки.
Франція та Великобританія у відповідь на це постачають Україні
високоточні ракети з дальністю 150 кілометрів,
щоб використовувати їх для знищення російських
радіолокаційних установок у незаконно анексованому Криму.
Через цю загрозу кораблі Військово-морських сил Росії
залишають порт Севастополь і вирушають на схід.
Протиповітряну оборону Одеси посилено - також за допомогою Заходу.
Український зерновий коридор з Одеси через Чорне море
вільний: це успіх для України.
Але Росія знову активізується:
з початком осені українські солдати повідомляють
про сильні атаки на східному фронті.
Росія знову атакує великі міста,
такі як Київ, електростанції та підстанції ракетами з повітря,
як це було в першу зиму війни.
Російські винищувачі можуть спокійно вести вогонь
з безпечної відстані. Тому що Україні не вистачає власних літаків.
Західні F-16 досі не захищають українське небо:
українських пілотів ще навчають у сусідній країні НАТО - Румунії.
Тож Росія все ще має перевагу в повітрі зі своїми винищувачами.
По суті, це питання протиповітряної оборони.
Одна протиповітряна оборона активна, інша пасивна.
Активна протиповітряна оборона - це винищувачі,
які завчасно не дозволяють наближатися винищувачам противника
на певну відстань, щоб здійснити обстріли.
Тобто збивають їх із більш-менш безпечної відстані.
Це одне. І пасивна протиповітряна оборона -
це коли все крутиться навколо якогось об'єкту інфраструктури,
тобто захищає цей об'єкт на різних рівнях, щоб його не можна було знищити.
Тим часом наземні західні сучасні озброєння Україна отримує.
Німеччина надала три системи ППО Iris-T (айріс-ті).
Ця новітня техніка може також надавати
радіолокаційну інформацію іншим пусковим базам.
Система протиповітряної оборони успішно працює в комплексі -
для протидії ракетам і безпілотникам.
Сьогодні Україна має найсучасніші системи ППО:
SAMP-T з Франції, Iris-T (айріс-ті) з Німеччини, Patriot із США.
Зенітні танки, такі як німецький Gepard,
успішно відбивають атаки безпілотників.
Із серпня 2023 року новозбудований завод боєприпасів у Німеччині
постачає в Україну ракети для танків Gepard.
Але Росія знову посилює обстріли інфраструктури.
Тепер із ще більшою кількістю безпілотників типу Lancet або Shahed.
Їх дешево виробляти, але дорого збивати.
У перший рік війни Україна мала перевагу у війні дронів.
Тепер Росія наздоганяє.
Ситуація зараз погіршується через технологічний розвиток.
Останніми місяцями Україна запровадила
нові дуже інноваційні системи озброєнь,
деякі з них такої якості, про яку раніше
можна було прочитати лише теоретично в текстах про майбутнє війни.
Візьмемо, наприклад, той факт, що тепер працюють цілі рої безпілотників,
які використовуються майже одночасно, наприклад, FPV-дрони.
Російська сторона скопіювала ці інноваційні ідеї.
І через те, що РФ все ще має функціонуючий
військово-промисловий комплекс - що наштовхує на запитання
про ефективність санкцій -
почала виробляти їх у великих масштабах.
Поле бою в Україні протягом перших двох років війни
постійно змінювалося. Тепер застосовується дедалі більше дронів,
більше електроніки.
І якщо зараз ви бачите, що кожна сторона
в принципі знає, що робить інша, особливо завдяки використанню
багатьох цих безпілотників, ми маємо те,
що багато хто називав останніми роками так званим прозорим полем бою.
Тобто що б не сталося на полі бою,
кожна сторона відразу бачить, що відбувається.
Тож перевага нині на боці того, хто має кращу радіоелектронну розвідку
та електронне ціленаведення.
Росія стає дедалі більш успішною в глушінні українських сигналів.
Експерти називають це контролем електромагнітного поля.
Це простір, де здійснюються радіопередачі,
де здійснюється зв'язок, де відбувається підйом і спуск безпілотників.
І якщо вам вдасться це контролювати,
ви можете знову засліпити ворога,
позбавивши його можливості використовувати свої дрони.
Для цього Україні потрібно більше сучасної військової техніки.
Їй потрібні передові технології, щоб подолати
перевагу Росії в солдатах, зброї та боєприпасах.
І щоб зрештою вийти з глухого кута і перемогти у війні.